the phrase famous civil servant should
actually be a contradiction in terms the
white horde machine is supposed to wear
away silently in the political
background
but this week you couldn't really escape
hearing or reading the name sue gray
she's holding an investigation into the
parties held in downing street and
elsewhere in whitehall during the
pandemic
conservative mps and number 10 plead
with us to wait for the conclusions of
her report as if she can determine the
future of boris johnson but actually she
can't that is in his own hands and those
of his party
but there are wider questions about
civil servants and the culture in
whitehall
the fda is the union representing senior
civil servant in whitehall and beyond
and its general secretary dave penman
joins me now good morning mr penman good
morning
um now i i don't mean to call it any
offence here but most people couldn't
name a civil servant if they tried but
obviously you'd have to be living under
rock not to have heard sue gray's name
um
do you think she's being set up to fail
by conservative mps and number ten
because um
actually
her investigation can't possibly answer
some of the questions that i raised with
uh
oliver dowden can it
no it can't i mean ultimately sue um
has been tasked with finding facts and
that's what the civil service is good at
the civil service um and its day job
advises ministers collects evidence and
as its duty under the civil service code
says it it should give evidence-based
advice and so even in these tricky
political issues what sue will do is
amass the evidence and present that
evidence to the prime minister
ultimately this is an internal
investigation and the prime minister
will have choices around what he does
with that report the degree to which he
publishes it what information he puts in
the public domain the decisions that
will be taken for civil servants because
some servants may face disciplinary
action around this but we then find
ourselves with this kind of perverse
position where if actually it
demonstrates as a question about whether
the prime minister reached the
ministerial code only the prime minister
himself can refer himself for an
investigation so it's not going to
deliver what and some people are put on
it but what it should do is deliver the
facts
but do you think well what do you think
then happens i mean she just says this
is what takes place i mean
is the prime minister then going to be
judge and jury
on himself i mean how does this work
well unfortunately that's the case
i mean ultimately as i said you know
there's a lot of public scrutiny here in
parliamentary scrutiny so i think you
know if you look if you look at kind of
previous investigations at the
investigation that was done into the
home secretary the prime minister sat on
for six months because he didn't like
the result and it was perfectly
inconvenient to him and when it was
first out of them we just ignored that
and so so ultimately the prime minister
is going to have to think about what the
consequences of dealing with any
inconvenient facts that come
from this report and the degree to which
he publishes all of it or a summary of
it but really the problem with our
current system is when it comes to the
prime minister himself he essentially
has a veto of whether he's investigated
and and i don't think that's good enough
you look at the government's elsewhere
in the country in scotland they're just
introducing a new system with
independent investigations and
independent education we really need a
better system for dealing with not only
the prime minister but ministers when it
comes to oversight of their conduct
i mean i i'm not sure whether you
actually represent uh sue gray whether
she's a member of the fda or not but
would you actually have said when this
started that actually she probably
shouldn't do that do this job and that
it should have gone as you say to
somebody completely independent of
government
even
independent of the uh
the advisor on ministers interests lord
gait
but well ultimately when this
investigation was originally launched it
wasn't just about the prime minister it
was a broader issue about number 10 and
the revelations that were in the public
domain at that time and more revelations
have come out and since then but
ultimately this is the job of a civil
servant a civil servant doesn't get to
choose and sue grey is a formidable
character and she has been used to
dealing with the most sensitive
political issues she was head of the
proprietary and ethics team at the cabin
office she's investigated ministers
before and given prime ministers very
difficult messages about those
investigations so so there isn't anyone
really in whitehall better to do it than
sugary herself but that's not really
good enough for the for the public the
public need to understand that this is
what the civil service does the civil
service is it's not independent but it's
permanent and it's impartial and it has
demonstrated time and time again that it
can present a prime minister reluctant
to receive those facts with the
unvarnished truth the difficulty here is
what happens then so so ultimately the
civil servants will do what they've been
asked to do and they'll do it to the
best of their ability they'll do it
under the civil service code where
they'll be dealing with facts and
evidence and tell the truth and then
we're left with how the prime minister
will determine on those facts
it's very difficult to tell exactly
what's going to happen here but of
course there's ender's gossip in
whitehall and some of it is in
newspapers today we um
we read that the number 10 strategy
appears to be to save boris johnson at
all costs uh
apparently it's called operation save
big dog
that probably means that if that's what
they want to do
some smaller dogs are going to get
thrown to the walls if i can
mangle the metaphor
do you think that's fair and and what
can you do about it because those
smaller dogs are going to be your people
aren't they
yeah well i mean ultimately everyone has
to be accountable for their conduct from
the most junior civil servant to the
prime minister when we were all under
those restrictions everyone had personal
choices to make all the time whether it
was at home or whether it was at work
and i don't think there's any hiding
from that but ultimately you have to ask
yourself some questions about how
a culture was created
in number 10 where this was deemed
acceptable and those in leadership
positions bear the most responsibility
for this i mean
there's talk in the papers of a civil
service culture that's not a civil
service culture i recognized after being
around whitehall for 20 years it might
be a number 10 culture but it's not a
civil service culture and and certainly
from from reading what others have said
it doesn't even seem like a number 10
culture from previous prime minister so
i think ultimately when you're looking
at responsibility those who lead a
culture and an organization quite a
small organization in number 10 there's
only about 400 staff who create an
environment where these sorts of
decisions can be taken never mind
potentially participating um in them
then i think that's where there's a
greater responsibility and sue gray will
know that sudhuri has worked in and
around government for decades she knows
um how these sort of manifestations
happen in cultures within management and
i'm sure she'll be alive to that fact as
well when she's considered on her
recommendation okay
let let me just uh pick you up on this
point about the culture because it's not
just number ten we saw it in department
for education we don't yet know where
else this kind of thing has happened
okay can you put your hand on your heart
and say that there isn't a culture of
you know six o'clock we've had a hard
day let's get in a bottle of a cheeky
merlot
across westminster i mean this thing
seems to be quite normalized and not
entirely contained to to west to number
10.
but well i would challenge that trevor
because what we've got is one incident
in another government department um
where there was a leave in doing a
mistake made and they held up their
hands quite quickly on that i mean if
you can imagine i get calls several
times a day from journalists trying to
find that on what was happening
elsewhere and none of that's come out of
course i can't say what's happened in
every government department but my
experience of 20 years around whitehall
would say this is not an environment and
a culture that has got that sort of
approach to it certainly not and when
you talk about in the middle of lockdown
you know this number 10 was not the only
bit of the civil service where people
were in at their desk working 24 hours a
day during and at the the pandemic you
know about a quarter of the civil
service has always been winning and
depends on dwp it's been it's been 50
percent throughout so ultimately you
know everyone has faced choices across
government and there are most real
stories coming out about elsewhere so i
think as far as i can
uh sure this is not a civil service
culture this really is about number 10.
all right
dave penman thank you very much indeed